So unless you've avoided news of all kinds
for the last four or five days, you probably
know that things in the United States have
gotten extremely intense on top of a global
hundred year pandemic corona virus, where
the United States has been one of the worst
hit countries, thanks in part to our failed
federal leadership.
We have seen the tragedy of George Floyd being
killed by police in Minnesota, set off a string
of extreme civil unrest.
And this includes examples of just about everything
you can imagine, both by protesters and by
those who are pretending to be protesters,
but actually have nefarious intentions and
by police as well.
And meanwhile, we are completely lacking anything
that would be called leadership from the Oval
Office, with Donald Trump doing everything
from calling for pro Trump protesters to gather
at the White House on Saturday night, which
they didn't.
All the way to a tweeting about essentially
release the hounds talking about Secret Service's
vicious dogs.
That would be unleashed on protesters who
breached the fence at the White House up to
and including of flying to Florida and taking
credit for a Space X launch of a Falcon nine
rocket carrying two astronauts to the International
Space Station while retweeting videos of himself
talking about all of it Saturday as protests
raged and buildings burned.
And I really spent a lot of time this weekend
thinking about what's the primary story here?
What's like the main analysis that has to
be done?
What's the lens through which we need to understand
what's happening in our country right now?
Because I wanted to come to you and give you
that point of view.
Here's really what this is about.
And the conclusion I came to is that there
is no one lens.
Things are more complicated than this is really
what's going on.
And I know that there are a ton of hot takes
about this.
If you look at Twitter lately, if you look
at cable news, everybody claims to hold the
real key.
They claim to say this is the truth filter
through which this should all be seen.
I'm here to tell you I don't have such a lens
for you because I believe any such lens is
too simplistic.
Now, if you want that simplistic analysis,
there are plenty available.
There's no question about it.
But to some degree, we sometimes are blinded
by narrative.
And in some cases, if all you have is a hammer,
everything looks like a nail.
Meaning if you want to see every issue as
being related to one problem, you're able
to find a way to do that, even if it's not
really the right or most robust analysis.
So I'm going to give you some examples and
then we'll get to what I think is a reasonable
analysis and way to think about all of this.
So one storyline we're hearing and we've heard
it from a lot of different people is this
is merely about race.
This is about white cops killing black people.
This is about white cops oppressing black
protesters.
This is about a fundamentally racist justice
system.
It's about a fundamental, fundamentally racist
society.
That's what the lens is.
Now, of course, rage at race is a massive
component that is causing understandable rage
among a lot of people.
But that analysis doesn't tell you everything
that you need to know.
Our economic system at its core, for example,
functions to stymie and suppress real change
and activism.
And it goes way beyond.
Race has racial implications, of course, but
you miss that if you make this only about
race.
Much of that economic system is certainly
rooted in supremacy, is along racial lines,
but a race only analysis falls short.
A lot of the hot takes we're seeing are only
about race.
Another perspective that is heavily represented
is that this is really about capitalism, right?
Any capitalist system is inevitably racist
and inevitably leads to this degree of social
unrest, arson, looting, property damage, police
violence against protesters, protester, violence
against police, protester and protester violence,
protesters versus looters.
That the idea is that is because of a capitalist
system.
Making this simply about capitalism ignores
the countless social democracies.
Right.
Which that's a form of capitalism is regulated
capitalism that are some of the places where
these issues of inequality and racial tensions
have been best dealt with around the world.
Some of the best examples, in fact, of functioning
societies with reduced income inequality reduce.
Racial inequality, social safety nets.
Trust in institutions.
Less corruption.
They are regulated versions of capitalism.
So I believe that the capitalism analysis
also fails.
Another lens that's being presented as the
lens is simply about police brutality.
Meaning?
This is about police brutality as what killed
George Floyd.
This is about police brutality as the problem
in the protests.
In other words, if it weren't for police brutality.
George Floyd would be alive if George Floyd
were alive.
We wouldn't be seeing these protests.
We at the protests are also just seeing further
police brutality.
Now, there is no shortage of police brutality
at the protests.
What happened to George Floyd is unconscionable.
But this is about so much more than that,
including economic and racial issues.
It's about the militarization of law enforcement
in the United States.
And there are people making it only about
that.
It's not only about that, but that's that's
a part of it.
When you militarize law enforcement, you create
overly aggressive policing.
You can argue that that played a role in George
Floyds Death.
Militarization is what led police in riot
gear in dozens of cities over the weekend
to use tear gas and rubber bullets and to
see media and random bystanders and even people
peacefully protesting, which is, of course,
their right to do horribly injured by police.
So militarization of law enforcement is another
huge problem in the US.
We've covered it, but it is not the only lens
that we need to be using.
So here's the reality.
When you think about this, and we often want
things to be black and white, we want to say
this is what this is really about.
The reality is this is a country of three
hundred and thirty one million people.
We have examples of everything you can imagine.
We have dozens of different problems that
relate to what we are now seeing.
Just this weekend, we saw sickening violence
done by police to protesters, including, for
example, an elderly man with a cane shoved
onto the ground by police.
And we saw police and I believe it was Michigan
show up until the protesters.
I'm putting down my weapons.
I'm with you.
Let's march together.
We saw protesters burn entire buildings and
brutalized business owners, including middle
aged women.
And yet we also saw protesters guard a police
officer who was separated from his squad on
Saturday night.
And this is the risk about the.
Out of context sharing of pictures and video
on social media.
Ten seconds from one protest and 15 from another.
And and I actually did some of this over the
weekend.
And I don't know that it was the best thing.
Not only does it lack immediate context, it
lacks broader context about all of the issues
that have gotten us to where we are now, including,
by the way, a complete lack of leadership
from the president.
And we're going to talk about that later,
which is why I'm not digging into it too much
right here.
So my message is what we are seeing is mostly
about systems and it is less about individuals.
You're seeing a ton of debates about what
portion of police are good versus bad, which
is very fraught terminology anyway.
Good, good and bad.
What portion of protesters have good or bad
intentions?
What portion of protesters are grassroots
members of the community versus out of town?
Astroturf is, as has been a growing narrative
over the weekend, used in part to discredit
the real and justified anger that protesters
have about what's going on in their communities.
The problem is, if you just argue about that,
if you spend your time on those questions,
well, eighty 82 percent of the protesters
are good or whatever you might say.
You're not really digging into the systemic
elements at play.
If we figure out it's 85 percent of the protesters
that are good instead of 80, then what?
It's good fodder for corporate media.
It does little for anybody else.
So I don't pretend to have one single unifying
theory about this.
This is what it's really about.
And at the exclusion of other things, that's
not something you're going to hear from me.
But what I can tell you for sure is that you
won't understand any of this if you don't
understand the context.
And that's where a lot of the local news coverage
of the protests has failed, which is a complete
lack of context.
Oh, somebody looted a Cheesecake Factory and
they came out with the cheesecake.
That's coverage that we saw.
Doesn't really tell us anything about what's
going on.
So racialized policing, combined with a two
tiered justice system for rich and poor, a
system that focuses on street crime at the
exclusion of white collar crime, combined
with an economic system that doesn't work
for a huge portion of the country.
In addition to right now having nearly 25
percent unofficial unemployment in the midst
of a 100 year pandemic, in addition to a complete
absence of.
Federal leadership from a president who tweeted
all weekend from his bunker at the White House,
combined with corporate media that really
is seeking to foment division rather than
find solutions, doesn't it's not a good recipe.
And then you add to that militarized law enforcement
that seems to always have money, despite we
supposedly lacking our supposed lack of money
for health care and education.
It's all of that stuff together.
Now, I want to be really clear.
This is not like a social justice intersectionality
analysis of race and gender and rule.
It's not that what it is, is an understanding
that we have systems in our country that are
bigger than any one protest or any one police
officer.
And only with that multi focus perspective
can you really get anything that we would
call an all encompassing analysis.
Let me give you another example of a false
debate.
Riots are good versus riots or bad or riots
are effective versus the riots are ineffective
or they are criminal or they are heroic.
First of all, a ton of this debate is actually
semantic in terms of some people are arguing
over whether riots are good or bad.
Others are arguing over what counts as a riot
versus a protest.
There's racialization of the language.
There's a lack of context, etc..
But what you really have to understand is
you can simultaneously say I'm against violence,
both against people.
And property, I believe is it is unlikely
that the violence will achieve much.
And yet, at the same time, I understand that
people have had it and I get what's going
on right.
Someone's son is killed by police and then
a window gets smashed.
It's hard to feel like these things are equivalent
in any way without needing to endorse property
damage.
We can understand that people have absolutely
had it.
People are sick and tired of the status quo.
And while I might not think we will achieve
change by breaking windows, I understand and
sympathize with the absolute anger and disgust
with these systems that protesters have.
Now, I have to tell you the argument that
the unrest has accomplished nothing.
I don't know if it's a good argument.
You all know that.
I have always said I favor legal put protests.
I'm against violence again, including against
most forms of property crime.
Over the weekend, we saw the officer who killed
George Floyd, Derek Schavan, arrested.
We saw Fox News Sunday devote an hour to the
protests, to George Floyd and to how coronavirus
disproportionately affects communities of
color with guests.
Cornell West.
I don't know that were it not for the national
unrest, we would have seen that be the Fox
News Sunday show.
I don't know.
I think that what's what we're seeing played
a role in what Fox News even decided to do
on Sunday.
Would we have seen Derek Schavan get arrested?
Would we potentially be seeing the other three
officers get arrested were it not for this
degree of unrest?
I don't know is the question.
It's less clear to me that this has accomplished
nothing, and that is separate from whether
these are tactics that I condone.
Last thing I want to be really clear here.
This is not like some Kumbayah segment where
everyone's thoughts are equally valid and
everyone is equally responsible for what's
going on.
That's not what this is.
But what we need to understand is that the
word privilege is often thrown around.
You're privileged.
If you say cops are mostly good and protect
you because a lot of people live in places
where the cops aren't primarily there to protect
you, or at least it certainly doesn't feel
that way.
If you're part of certain communities or you're
privileged to be against property crime during
protests because you live somewhere safe and
the systems work for you, and you can't possibly
imagine what it's like to actually be in the
position that a lot of the protesters are
in in some way.
All of those allegations are correct.
And yet this is not so much about individual
privilege.
It's, again, systems that aren't working for
large swaths of people.
And that gets me to my last thought in history.
We've seen unrest lead to movements which
lead to activism, which will often enter the
political and legal space, which at some point
will end up being decided by a judge somewhere.
Look at Brown v. Board of Education, the landmark
decision decision that said states can't segregate
schools by race.
That was in 1954.
It started in 1951 in Kansas.
It involved three years of activism, protests,
consensus building.
And eventually it was a Supreme Court decision
under Earl Warren that decided nine to zero
on the court.
Schools can't racially segregate as we figure
out what needs to happen next.
Do not miss the forest for the trees that
may come one, two or three years down the
line.
If what is going on now will lead to change.
It may come down to who is on the Supreme
Court in one, two or three years.
I don't even have to tell you what that means
about a decision we all have to make five
months from now, because you all know exactly
what that decision is.